[Musique]
voilà
et maintenant
une émission pour vous mesdames
c'est la séquence du oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
barack senior dans les images
[Musique]
si bas si non je vois si je veux pas le
faire si je peux le faire c'était prévu
michel oui non mais bon j'aurais pu ne
pas le faire quand même ne soit pas
enfants c'était prévu lis tu vas tir
viré après non non non pas ça j'aime
bien l'antique après dornic anciens la
plus d'émissions non à tombouctou sais
tu le fais c'était prévu ne soit pas
enfants moi je vous avertis c'est une
catastrophe
c'est un film d'horreur c'est pas
possible que je le fasse donc c'est une
horreur envoie la musique
[Musique]
non c'est vrai
changer de chaîne je vous en supplie
changé
jeudi delon et belmondo leur carrière
est foutue j'avais signé un contrat avec
eux ils m'ont dit jamais étude des
habits en public
jamais vous gêne je vous dis pas ce que
j'ai
maman excuse moi c'est qu'ancien et
chavannes ils m'ont pris mon force et je
te dis pas ce qu'ils m'ont dit mais moi
zèle
[Musique]
on se tient bon
on se tient
je vais aller jusqu'au bout les façons
dire avoir un scandale j'enlève tout
j'enlève tout petit m'ont dit tu te
déshabille je me déshabille les grolles
des grolles
ouais vous moquez page et alors ça
s'appelle le syndrome du couscous et en
plus je peux vous dire un truc c'est que
au moins on peut s'accrocher
j'ai pas peur toutes les façons nord
heureusement que le ridicule ne tue pas
je vais jusqu'au bout
j'ai pas peur
tu as vu la musique bébel excuse moi ta
carrière est situé préparez vous non je
veux voir
non sens écologique non non mais vous
aller vomir je veux pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non je veux pas
charente est un [ __ ]
salo chavannes il a fait il bon voilà on
se cache tous à vos intérêts j'attendais
les socialo irish havane monsieur péter
florrick anciens aussi oui car à pattes
et là alors le pdt les mecs c'est une
tradition l'habitude bah oui bah là là
je sens que ça va
alors avant avant moi je je veux bien
mais c'est dangereux quand même avant
d'aller au fond des choses je rêve ou le
déni un petit peu vos projets qu'est ce
qui va se passer là maintenant tout de
suite je sors donc mon livre qui
s'appelle sans famille seydoux a neuf
ans le 15 novembre
je prépare l'olympia du à partir du 7
janvier je serai donc à l'olympia des
locations sont des locations sont
ouvertes c'est un très très bon
publicitaire il est très très bon je
vous laisse à tous que c'est là bas
c'est le jingle pelé mec qui veut qu'on
a vu la rampe les mecs c'est je vous
laisse j'ai dit oui
non moi je veux bien cela dit ça me
dérange pas tu vois vraiment pas ce que
je me déshabille jeunes des ados
ça c'est vous qui aurez vous la raconter
[Musique]
samedi
[Applaudissements]
et je prends racine
ou pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment du
tu as
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non non non non non non non non non non
ah ah
[Musique]